le drame s'est produit derrière la porte
de cet appartement situé au troisième
étage d'un immeuble de la rue pergaud
jeudi après midi
le compagnon de la victime alerte les
pompiers au téléphone il explique avoir
tué sa femme
sur place les secours découvrent une
jeune femme inconsciente sur le sol une
plaie à la tête
dans un état critique un délice à 21 ans
et héliporté vers le chu de besançon
elle décédera dans la nuit des suites de
ses blessures
dans le quartier c'est la consternation
j'aurai donc comment allez-vous était
très très très gentil ça m'a choqué
beaucoup même hier et paris allaient au
travail mais j'ai dû y aller quand même
mais sur son visage devant moi et son
sourire et tout ça sa gentillesse est
tout le monde déménage dans les blocs
elle était aimée à super u par tous les
clients on voyait qu'elle le couple
résidait à mandeure depuis moins d'un an
et était parents d'une petite fille de
13 mois
présente au moment des faits à dellys à
travailler comme caissière dans ce
supermarché une employée modèle
souriante et pleine de vie selon le
directeur
le mari âgé de 23 ans et sans emploi
après le drame la petite fille a été
confié à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
le père de famille a été placé d'office
dans un hôpital psychiatrique avant de
pouvoir être entendue par les enquêteurs
quant à la jeune mère une autopsie sera
pratiquée en début de semaine prochaine
afin de connaître les circonstances de
sa mort